it's great to welcome back to the
program Molly McHugh who is a foreign
policy and strategy consultant and an
information warfare expert Molly you had
this great article in Politico a few
days ago titled Trump handed Putin a
stunning victory and it had everything
to do with what we saw at the g20 in
Germany as well as what came out of the
I don't even know if private is the
right term since we've gotten a readout
of this meeting but this meeting between
Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin and you
go into detail about what we've learned
in terms of whose priorities seemed to
be met and acquiesced to during this
meeting and a whole bunch of other stuff
so let's sort of start at the at the top
level what came out of the meeting
that's most notable to you I think you
know coming out of the meeting right
away I think that the most obvious thing
is the warmth between the two leaders
there was obviously a very amicable
meeting they were both trying to make a
good impression on the other and this is
very notable I think but it's a readout
from secretary Tillerson just after the
meeting sort of laid out three key
deliverables one of those sort of began
with this idea that President Trump
raised the idea of the election hacking
President Putin and then if they sort of
agreed well we're never going to agree
on this so let's move on and move
forward and find ways to work together
and those will now be in the form of a
joint cybersecurity working group the
notion of which is completely absurd and
that we will mutually agree to find ways
not to meddle in each other's internal
affairs and that we will find there's a
new ceasefire agreement announced on a
very limited way on on a part of
southwestern Syria and what's so
stunning about all of these things is
they they line up right behind the
Russian there it is in the first its
saying
well Russia probably didn't meddle in
anything in the US because now we're
going to work with them on finding
solutions to all of our cybersecurity
challenges that we all have and this is
just absolute nonsense the idea that
we're going to work with the country
that our intelligence services know
attacked us to find quotes
Ellucian to these problems if that
working group is ever formed the only
purpose of it will be to hand
intelligence on the United States to
Russia
the second is again this acquiescence to
this long-term Russian narrative at
everything wrong inside Russia every
time there's a demonstration or a
protest against Putin is because the US
is funding it or George Soros is funding
it or some outside forces mobilizing
people against the great leader so again
this is just sort of this Russian
narrative nonsense and in Syria I've
also written about this fairly
extensively in Politico but it will be
impossible for the United States to work
with Russia in Syria we do not share
common goals and hearing the Secretary
of State's say that we do and that we
will find ways to work together moving
forward when Russia's alliance in Syria
is Iran and Iranian militias and
Hezbollah and Hamas and other very
unsavory forces again this is just sort
of shocking but it's an absolute
acquiescence of US leadership in Europe
and in the Middle East and in the world
at the top level there's been the
reaction from some apologists some of
whom have R actually written to me who
say wait a second what why why are
people against having better relations
with Russia shouldn't we be applauding
that our relationship with Russia seems
to have seems to be improving what's
wrong with that approach so it's um I
think those of us that have worked in
the Russian periphery for the last
decade are particularly sensitive to
this narrative because this is always
what the force was that the Kremlin
cultivates um typically they're not
marine lepen like riggers they're not
the super pro-russia super Pro putti
political actors that's usually the
question that they bring wouldn't it be
better if we could have better relations
with Russia and the answer to that is
obviously yes it would be great if we
could have a better relationship with
Russia the problem being Russia has
never demonstrated that it would like to
have a better relationship with us
particularly with the United States of
America which it still declares as its
primary enemy in the world and until we
accept that language and hold them
accountable for what they're doing to
our own country first and foremost the
fact that there will be no consequences
for Russia for what they did to American
society in our election is absolutely
unconscionable and it can a complete
abdication of responsibility from the
president
so that alone is bad enough but it's not
just that it's everything else
everywhere Russia is sort of advancing
its interests through military means
through informational means through
intelligence operations through
financial and political operations where
they are not held accountable for
directly disrupting the interests of
other nations they will keep doing these
things and and they will keep using
these sort of shadowy tactics and shadow
warfare to achieve their interests in
the world and that is directly to our
disadvantage and to the disadvantage of
American security and American
prosperity and a number of other things
along those lines were still learning
the the extent to which this Donald
Trump jr. meeting with a Russian lawyer
and those revelations are going to
impact the broader investigation into
Trump and Russia collusion but putting
the specifics of that aside uh just for
a second we're continuing to see some
defenders of Donald Trump who seem
convinced that regardless of whether or
not there were attempts from Russia to
influence or collude with the United
States for Donald Trump's benefit that
they've sort of gotten nothing out of it
right and I hear often that hey how
stupid was it for Russia to try to get
Trump elected because Trump's done
nothing for them nothing has improved
for Russia since Donald Trump got into
power we've got a pretty significantly
growing list of ways in which Donald
Trump's election has so far been a
pretty significant game-changer for
Russia hasn't it and this includes the
three issues that that you write about
that came out of that g20 meeting
between Trump and Russia this includes
the immediate attempts to start
rethinking sanctions and return these
two compounds in I believe it's Maryland
in New York it's quite a list absolutely
and and you know Russia has been very
clear about that the spokesman for Putin
came out after just yesterday so after
the meeting and said yeah we agreed to
all sorts of stuff and we expect
President Trump to start delivering he
hasn't yet if he doesn't we're going to
take retaliatory measures and that was
really notable and I think this is it so
they're sort of the tactical list of
items is the key thing to look at you
know are these are we making
sanctions are we giving back diplomatic
properties when they have done nothing
to be held accountable for the action
that took those away you know all these
other things on the list that people are
keeping a close eye on but near the
other part of that piece that I wrote in
Politico was about the rhetoric that
President Trump used in Poland and I
think this is actually the greatest
concession to to Putin it from this trip
and for the last well since he since he
entered the Kremlin but but certainly
for the last ten years and especially
since just before the annexation of
Crimea Putin has been aggressively
advancing this new narrative of the
world that has been sort of based on his
own decade-long revision of history and
everybody's placed in history part of
which is this sort of repetition that
that democratic governance is
essentially an anomaly in history and
moving forward it will move back to more
traditional systems but just what you've
heard from President Trump was this
really remarkable you know how do you
give a speech in Poland without
mentioning democracy and it's virtually
impossible for an American president to
do that and yet he did he didn't talk
about our alliances he talked about
sovereignty which is exactly how Russia
talks about itself he didn't talk about
values he talked about this idea of
civilization which absent the concept of
Western values means a very different
thing that is anchored in a
thousand-year-old history and sort of
has a more ethno-religious identity it
has very little to do with the
post-world War - Liberal Democratic
World Order
he didn't talk about rights he talked
about traditional values and identity
and these ideas of Destiny and all of
these things sort of linked to this
liberal worldview that handful of
leaders many of whom Trump has given
significant time to including Putin
including the leader of Poland including
people like Viktor Orban and Hungary the
leader in the Philippines but these
people who espouse this new liberal
worldview this idea that the liberal
democracy small-l liberal democracy but
but the concept of what has given the
United States its greatest security and
prosperity in history it's somehow
something that needs to be undone and
hearing the American president repeat
those ideas and sort of align the u.s.
behind them during
speech in Poland it's very significant I
think we're very slow to hear what he's
actually telling us this was not a new
speech it was the continuation of his
American carnage inauguration speech but
on an international stage and until we
hear what he is telling us which is that
he does not believe in the core values
that we believe are essential to our
identity in the world he is telling his
core supporters in the United States
these are things that are no longer
important and those ideas are starting
to spread and people are starting to
echo them and this is really going to
change how our allies view us how we are
positioned in the world and our own it
comes to to be secure and to access
markets and to grow our economy this is
going to have really significant impact
on the United States of America well
that's why that's why Molly I'm
concerned when I see we've got some
pretty interesting recent polling about
how significantly the reputation of the
US as a trustworthy Ally is the place to
go when you need to talk about whether
it be a technology to fight climate
change or whatever the case may be the
reputation of the US has already been
pretty significantly damaged under
Donald Trump and I feel as though there
are many Trump supporters who see this
as sort of validation like if other
countries don't like what we're doing it
must be because it's so good for us and
bad for them but it sort of misses that
this is not good the us standing being
affected in this way around the world
it's bad for national security it's bad
for economics it's bad for education
technology but this is going to affect
people whether or not they realize it
isn't it absolutely I think part of this
is that our leaders have done a very bad
job explaining this for a really long
time and that matters and you know part
of the reason that it's been so easy to
give the hardcore Trump supporters these
very quick talking points that they've
echoed about NATO being worthless and
everybody being out to get us and
everything's unfair and trade is unfair
is that nobody really explains what has
been important about the last 70 years
of our history I think this notion that
Europe is a free rider and it's just
sort of been mooching off the US since
the Marshall Plan and we've been doing
everything for them and it doesn't
matter to us and we should stop is
really really off base and I mean the
yes we invested a ton of money in
European economy and security but what
that did was bill
a market for our goods it moved us from
being a significant global economy to
being a global superpower economy it
moved us from being a significant global
power to being you know the superpower
in terms of military and power in the
world and all of that was because we
built a market and we built an alliance
that that amplified our power and our
reach into the world and that's really
significant and we have to understand
what that means
we've been speaking with Molly McHugh
foreign policy and strategy consultant
information warfare expert the article
is in Politico Trump handed Putin a
stunning victory Molly great is always
to talk to you thanks so much for having
me on